hello everybody i am very excited right
now to sit down and watch the batman
official trailer number three um we also
got a release date and like confirmation
of when the movie's actually coming out
i'm not at a point where i'm like 100
sold on this movie despite being a huge
batman fan i think robert pattinson is a
fantastic actor paul dano is one of my
favorite actors but like i mean i'm not
at the point where i don't want to see
more marketing you know how sometimes
you see so many trailers for a movie or
a game that you're like i'm good i'm
gonna see it stop showing it to me
yes i'm going to see this regardless but
i'm not like you know they haven't over
saturated it i guess is the concise way
of saying what i'm going to say so
i'm actually just super excited um just
excited to see another one don't feel
like i'm done yet it's like just
stranding all over again so let's do it
this is the batman official trailer
number three
and i am watching it on ign
oh my
hello beautiful
i wouldn't be bothering you here but
your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could i like the
call
a
oh that's interesting i like the car a
lot more than i did he has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
that's cute the riddler
is asking for you
the killer left this for the batman why
is he writing to you
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strays
she's so good
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
rude i'm so excited to see paul jonathan
oh my gosh
you lied to me
[Music]
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know shuffle delany
why are you under there
what are you hiding selena don't throw
your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
oh man
it's your violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice
i feel like i need to watch this ten
more times i'm like so like
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh you love to see it you love
to see it
um a couple of things one
i don't know if it was just me but i
picked up on a slight suggestion of the
insinuation that the wanes are up to no
good which is always interesting um the
telltale batman games dove into that a
little bit
and it was really interesting the way
that they tackled
bruce and batman's uh reaction to
finding out that the waynes were not
necessarily good people and also i
really like it when
uh
batman media
tries to make sure that the audience
doesn't know more than batman does so
like when you have a story where you're
retelling something um like say this is
long halloween if the audience already
knows what happens it makes us smarter
than batman so i like it if they change
canon and they don't um have things
based completely off of a comic book or
an existing property so that we don't
feel smarter than batman so that we feel
like we're learning things at the same
time as him i think that that's a really
interesting challenge that people face
when there are so many batman comics and
so much batman media already um but that
that is interesting i like it uh again
all the pull down and stuff i'm
halfway through this trailer i was like
i wish they were focusing more on the
villains because like while i love
batman that's really why i love gotham
is the villains i think that batman has
the best cast of villains of all of them
um but i think that actually works in
our favor that we're getting a little
bit more of of
i would say bruce and batman less of
bruce really this is more about
his early batman before he's really
developed the bruce side um i still
really don't like
his appearance in this shot it's this
one shot that i don't like
i don't know
it doesn't matter i i it really doesn't
matter it's not like it's gonna ruin the
film for me i just don't picture any
version of uh
of this billionaire kid
just
styling himself this way but
it's fine
throw my expectations aside it's better
for me in the long run anyway
um
but yeah i feel like you know he's going
to be learning bruce we know that it's
an early version of him they said it was
based on kurt cobain which i also don't
love the sound of or inspired by that's
a weird choice to me but whatever
i also thought it was interesting
to hear somebody blaming him for not
being more
philanthropic which
is true um you know there are a lot of
themes uh that recurring in
a lot of again batman media
widespread that kind of tackle
the idea that uh batman is causing the
crime that if he were to leave gotham
then the villains would all go too um
and that's a really interesting thing to
dive into um i think the action looks
awesome i'm really liking the selena
kyle stuff
she's not too cheesy i feel like we've
definitely seen her be overly cheesy in
the past whereas in this i i really like
her so
i do want to watch it again i'm just
here to unmask the truth about this yes
we're getting like ridley clues and
stuff part of this too
but we're not just we're not getting a
lot of as a character and i think
that's for the best oh you're really not
as smart as i thought you were
bruce that's so great
i love that holy [ __ ]
i
[Music]
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
yeah
i do feel like this movie realistically
like based on the the
uh trailers if it is as good as i have
you know hyped it up to be in my mind
which is never a good place to start
does seem like it's going to be very
much about identity they're focusing on
the wanes a lot they're focusing on an
early
batman and maybe we'll see the bruce
persona come out um maybe this is what
forces him to be more of a
philanthropist and start spending money
kind of lavishly around the city um
and you know even on charity efforts
i think
i think i'm happy with with the glimpses
we're seeing but not knowing too much um
and i'm still very very very curious
let's see what the internet thought we
can't see dislike ratios anymore i guess
yeah
it's true
very smooth delivery there shot from the
back of the batmobile when penguins car
rolls is perfect yeah that is a very
nice shot
they'll end the movie with a cliffhanger
that has batman needing to solve riddles
24 7 riddles throughout gotham
maybe
i doubt that i think he'll probably
catch him
cinematic theme totally resembles arkham
knight especially when he's looking
through the dino with all the cops
absolutely that that was like the
opening of that game
felony to make a movie or show about
catwoman without referencing nine lives
not saying cat got your tongue would be
a misdemeanor i love that super true
very good
i agree with silent pilot here there's a
part where batman looks genuinely scared
and human um
yeah i do think
if they do this right
it could be really really interesting um
so hard to say
there's a lot on the line i'm just
trying not to get myself too hyped up i
won't be disappointed which has been
working out for me pretty well in the
last few years
but it seems like a lot of people are
really excited so
yeah all seems positive the fact that he
used the gun to do anything but shoot
makes this movie even better that's
gotta be my favorite shot is batman
beating people up with a gun
wherever it was
i don't remember exactly but very big
fan of that how ridiculous here
[Music]
oh i love it
great very excited um can't wait to go
see it uh let me know what you all think
i'm alana i hope you're all having a
wonderful time hope everyone had a great
christmas and i hope you all have a
happy new year i will see you guys next
time bye